WE HAVE TO HARDEN OUR SCHOOLS,
NOT SOFTEN THEM.
A GUN FREE ZONE TO A KILLER OR
SOMEBODY WHO WANTS TO BE A
KILLER, THAT'S LIKE GOING IN FOR
THE ICE CREAM.
IF THEY REALLY HAVE THE
APTITUDE.
NOT EVERYBODY HAS AN APTITUDE
FOR A GUN BUT IF THEY HAVE THE
APTITUDE, I THINK A CONCEALED
PERMIT FOR HAVING TEACHERS AND
LETTING PEOPLE KNOW THERE ARE
PEOPLE IN THE BUILDING WITH A
GUN, YOU WON'T HAVE, IN MY
OPINION, YOU WON'T HAVE THE
SHOOTINGS.
WHAT I RECOMMEND IS THE PEOPLE
WHO CARRY, WE GIVE THEM A BONUS.
>> TEACHERS ARE EMOTIONAL.
PEOPLE ARE EMOTIONAL.
I THINK THAT'S A HUGE FACTOR.
>> Bret: THE DEBATE CONTINUES
ABOUT SECURING SCHOOLS, THIS
IDEA OF ARMING TEACHERS OR
PERSONNEL SOME WAY, WE GET THE
BREAKING NEWS FROM THE SHERIFF
AND BROWARD COUNTY THAT THERE
WAS AN ARMED OFFICER.
THE SHERIFF ISRAEL SAYING DEPUTY
SCOTT PETERSON WAS OUTSIDE AND
NEVER WENT INSIDE THE BUILDING
DURING THE SHOOTING.
IT LASTED 6 MINUTES.
THERE IS VIDEO OF HIM STANDING
OUTSIDE.
HE WAS SUSPENDED WITHOUT PAY BUT
HE CHOSE TO RESIGN AFTER THIS
CAME OUT.
THE SHERIFF NOTED THE
INVESTIGATION WILL CONTINUE BUT
HE WAS ARMED AND OUTSIDE THE
SCHOOL AS THE SHOOTING WAS
HAPPENING.
WHAT'S ANOTHER ELEMENT TO THIS
PARTICULAR SHOOTING, AS THE
DISCUSSION CONTINUES ABOUT WHAT
TO DO NEXT.
LET'S BRING THE PANEL.
STEPHEN HAYES EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
"THE WEEKLY STANDARD."
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO AND MOLLIE HEMINGWAY,
SENIOR EDITOR AT "THE
FEDERALIST."
INTERESTING DEVELOPMENT IN THAT
THERE WAS SOMEONE THERE ARMED
BUT DID NOT ACT.
>> THERE WAS A GOOD GUY WITH THE
GUN OUTSIDE AND THERE WAS A BAD
GUY WITH A GUN INSIDE.
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK OUT THAT
IF A GOOD GUY WITH A GUN IS THEY
ARE HE'S GOING TO SAVE
EVERYBODY.
HE DIDN'T IN THIS CASE.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTS BUSH?
TWEETING THIS MORNING SAYING "I
WILL STRONGLY BE PUSHING
COPPERHEADS OF BACKGROUND CHECKS
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON MENTAL
HEALTH, RAISE AGED 21, END SALE
OF BUMP STOCKS.
CONGRESS IS IN A MOOD TO DO
SOMETHING.
HE GOES ON AND ON ABOUT
SPECIFICS.
SAYS THAT THE NRA ARE GOOD
PEOPLE BUT THERE IS NO
INDICATION FROM THE NRA OR
CONGRESS THAT THEY ARE READY TO
GO.
>> IT DEPENDS ON WHICH
PROVISION.
THE NRA HAS SHOWN FLEXIBILITY ON
BUMP STOCKS.
THE IDEA THAT YOU WOULD LIVE
MEANT GUN PURCHASING TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE 21 YEARS OF AGE IS GOING
TO BE A VERY DIFFICULT SELL TO A
WHOLE SWATH OF PEOPLE.
>> Bret: IT IS THAT FOR
HANDGUNS.
>> A LOT OF WHAT PEOPLE THINK
THEY KNOW ABOUT MASS SHOOTINGS,
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF STATISTICS.
ONLY 10% OF MASS SHOOTINGS DONE
BY MEN IN THAT 18 TO 21-YEAR-OLD
CATEGORY.
THE AVERAGE AGE IS HIGHER.
IT LIMITS GUN RIGHTS WITHOUT
BEING SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP.
THEY IDEA ABOUT ARMING
SCHOOLTEACHERS IS INTERESTING.
THERE ARE TEACHERS WHO ARE ABLE,
CERTAIN TEACHERS WHO WOULD BE
QUALIFIED AND HAVE THE RIGHT
SENSIBILITY.
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE CAPABLE AND
QUALIFIED, MAYBE THAT WOULD BE A
WAITER, WHEN YOU HAVE FAILURES,
THESE BUREAUCRATIC FAILURES,
VARIOUS REDUNDANCIES MIGHT HELP.
>> Bret: CRITICS ARE GOING TO
POINT TO THIS GUY WHO HAD THE
GUN AND WAS TRAINED AND HE WAS
STANDING OUTSIDE AND DIDN'T ACT.
HOWEVER, SUPPORTERS OF IT SAY
EITHER THE TEACHER GETS TRAINED
OR PERHAPS IT'S LIKE AN AIR
MARSHAL PROGRAM WHERE THERE IS
SOMEONE IN THE SCHOOL, LIKE ON
AIRPLANES, DESIGNED TO PROTECT
THE SCHOOL PRIVATELY.
>> I THINK THAT'S THE BIG
CHALLENGE.
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION HERE, AS
OF PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES ARE
OFFERING THESE THINGS AS IF IT
IS A PANACEA.
IT'S A DIFFICULT PROBLEM.
YOU CAN MAKE AN IMPACT IN
CERTAIN WAYS POTENTIALLY WITH
SOME PROPOSALS, AS MOLLIE
SUGGESTED BUT WE SHOULD BE
REALISTIC.
THERE IS NO PANACEA.
IT'S A PROBLEM GROWING WITH
ALARMING FREQUENCY.
IT'S WORTH LOOKING AT HARDENING
THE SCHOOLS.
I AM SKEPTICAL OF ARMING
TEACHERS.
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU CARRIED
OUT.
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE AN OBVIOUS
SOLUTION.
A LOT OF THINGS BEING TALKED
ABOUT RIGHT NOW, BACKGROUND
CHECKS, INCREASING THE AGE, THEY
HAVE BEEN TALKED ABOUT AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
IT'S HARD TO SEE, IF YOU RAISE
THE AGE, A DETERMINED
20-YEAR-OLD NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET THE KIND OF WEAPON HE WOULD
WANT TO GET TO SHOOT UP A
SCHOOL.
>> STILL ABLE TO DO IT.
>> Bret: WILL MOVE THINGS THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT.
MENTAL HEALTH, VIDEO GAMES, THE
CULTURE, THEY HAVE NOT BEEN IN
THE CONVERSATION AS MUCH.
>> THE QUESTION IS, WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO DO ABOUT IT?
THE NRA IS FOR PEOPLE -- PEOPLE
ON THE PROHIBITED LIST FOR GUNS.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT TALKING
ABOUT WITH MENTAL HEALTH?
HE HAS OFF-THE-CUFF SAID WE
SHOULD HAVE MENTAL INSTITUTIONS
AGAIN.
MANY WERE CLOSED YEARS AGO.
THE DETAILS REALLY MATTER WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE
THINGS.
VIDEO GAMES?
WHAT DOES HE WANT TO DO?
DOES HE WANT TO BAN THEM?
THERE ALREADY ARE PARENTAL
CONTROLS.
WE NEED TO HEAR MORE ABOUT WHAT
HE WANTS TO DO.
>> THERE IS NOT A STRONG LINK
BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
AND MASS SHOOTINGS.
THERE IS A LOT WE NEED TO KNOW
BUT SOMETIMES WHAT PEOPLE
PROPOSE, IT HAS BIGGER
DOWNSIDES.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE KNOW IS
TALKING ABOUT MASS SHOOTINGS CAN
ACT AS CONTAGION.
WE DON'T WANT TO LIMIT PRESS
FREEDOM BECAUSE IT'S CONTRIBUTED
TO THE PROBLEM.
>> YOU DON'T NEED TO LIMIT PRESS
FREEDOM.
YOU CAN HAVE JOURNALISTS AND
JOURNALISTIC INSTITUTIONS TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY BY NOT GLORIFYING
OR GLAMORIZING PEOPLE COMMITTING
THESE SHOOTINGS.
SOME OF THE COVERAGE I'VE SEEN
BORDERS ON DOING THAT.
EVERYBODY LAMENTS WHAT NIKOLAS
CRUZ DID.
BUT THERE'S A SENSE OF CELEBRITY
THAT IS CREATED AROUND HIM THAT
I THINK PEOPLE WHO ARE WATCHING
THIS AT HOME, YOUNG KIDS WHO
MIGHT -- WHO AREN'T POPULAR WHO
MIGHT WANT TO BECOME POPULAR OR
NOTORIOUS LOOK AT THAT AND SAY
THAT IS MY ANSWER.
>> Bret: EVERY DAY WE ARE
LEARNING SOMETHING NEW.
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT THE OFFICER
OUTSIDE WITH THE GUN.
NOW IT'S BEING REVEALED IN THE
NEWS CONFERENCE SECURITY FOOTAGE
AT THE SCHOOL WAS ON A 20 MINUTE
DELAY.
THE OFFICERS WERE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING THAT WAS 20 MINUTES
BEFORE.
>> THAT'S INCREDIBLE TO ME.
THE SCHOOL HAS TO BE HARDENED
BUT THEY CAN HAVE LIVE VIDEO.